SWAMP.
WE PAY MORE TAXES HERE.
ALL RIGHT, TUCKER, GREAT SHOW.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO ANTI.
TONIGHT, THE DEMOCRATIC
PSYCHOTIC MINDLESS ANTI-TRUMP
RAGE PSYCHOSIS SINKING TO NEW
DEPTHS OF DEPRAVITY IN WHAT WAS
A DISASTROUS DAY FOR THEM AS
THEY PURSUE TRUMP EVERY SECOND,
MINUTE, HOUR OF EVERY DAY,
THEY'RE HURTING THE COUNTRY,
THEY'RE RIPPING THIS COUNTRY
APART, JUST FOR A CHEAP,
BASELESS, POLITICAL HEAD JOB.
AND AFTER TODAY'S TOTAL BS, IF
YOU WANT TO CALL IT, IMPEACHMENT
HEARING ON CAPITOL HILL, YOUR
BLOOD SHOULD BE BOILING BUT YOU
HAVE THE ANSWER IN 335 DAYS NOW
INSTEAD OF PRESENTING ACTUAL
EVIDENCE, DEMOCRATS THOUGHT WE,
THE STUPID, SMELLY, TRUMP
SUPPORTING WALMART SHOPPERS THAT
BELIEVE IN GOD OF AMERICA NEED
TO BE EDUCATED ON THE VIRTUES OF
IMPEACHMENT.
SO, TO EDUCATE, WE, THE PEOPLE,
THE MASSES OF PEOPLE, THEY
HAULED IN THREE HYPERPARTISAN,
FAR LEFT, HOLIER THAN THOU
SANCTIMONIOUS SELF-RIGHTEOUS
IVORY TOWER LAW SCHOOL
PROFESSORS TO TEACH US ABOUT THE
INSTITUTION.
THE REALLY GOOD NEWS TONIGHT IS
TO THEIR CREDIT, REPUBLICAN,
THEY WERE UNITED.
THEY FOUGHT BACK IN A BIG AND
EFFECTIVE WAY.
CONGRESSMAN COLLINS, JORDAN,
AND, YEP, MATT GATES, ROCK STARS
TODAY ALONG WITH OTHERS, AND THE
GOP SOLE WITNESS CONSTITUTIONAL
SCHOLAR, JONATHAN TUTURLEY, A
DEMOCRAT, HE VOTED FOR TRUMP,
DIDN'T VOTE FOR OBAMA, ALSO
VOTED FOR THE CLINTONS, RAN
CIRCLES AROUND THE LIBERAL
PROFESSORS SITTING NEXT TO HIM.
MAYBE THAT'S BECAUSE HIS
JUDGMENT WASN'T CLOUDED BY AS HE
DISCUSSED RAGE AND HATE AND
HYSTERIA.
THE DEMOCRATS' THREE WITNESSES
ON THE OTHER HAND WERE CLEARLY
SUFFERING FROM STAGE FOUR, A
CASE OF MASSIVE TRUMP DER
RANGEMENT SYNDROME DISCONNECTED
FROM ALL TROUPE TRUTH AND
REALITY, UNC LAW PROFESSOR
WORKED FOR THE CLINTONS IN THEIR
ADMINISTRATION, AL GORE'S SENATE
CAMPAIGN, A MONTH AGO, HE
OFFERED AN IMPASSIONED PIECE IN
THE ATLANTIC.
AND THE FELLOW WITNESSES,
HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR, NOAH
FELDMAN, HE'S BEEN LOOKING FOR
WAYS TO IMPEACH TRUMP SINCE
2017.
A FEW WEEKS AFTER THE PRESIDENT
WAS SWORN IN, THAT GUY FELT
PRESIDENT TRUMP COULD BE
IMPEACHED OR HIS USE OF THE
TERM, "FAKE NEWS," I KID YOU
NOT.
THE PERFECT IVORY TOWER LAW
PROFESSOR, SEEMINGLY HATING FREE
SPEECH, DUE PROCESS, PRESUMPTION
OF INNOCENCE, AND CANNOT BE
COUNTED ON TO SEEK TRUTH AND
JUSTICE.
DAYS LATER, THE PRESIDENT
CLAIMED THE PRESIDENT COULD BE
IMPEACHED BECAUSE OF AN AD FOR
MARALARGO.
AND NOT TO BE OUTDONE, FELDMAN
WROTE HE COULD BE IMPEACHED OVER
HIS TWEETS ABOUT WIRETAPPING.
HIS DER RANGED ANTI-TRUMP BIAS
PALES IN COMPARISON OF THE THIRD
WITNESS, IVORY TOWER PROFESSOR
IS HER NAME, THE DEVOUT LIBERAL,
DONATED THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO
HILLARY CLINTON, BARACK OBAMA,
AND IN JUNE, WOW, WHO IS SHE
SUPPORTING FOR PRESIDENT?
ANOTHER $1,000 FOR THAT
SOCIALIST.
YES, $NEW GREEN DEAL, ELIZABETH
WARREN.
AND ONCE APPEARED AT A PODCAST
CALLED VERSUS TRUMP WHERE SHE
TRASHED CONSERVATIVES.
HER INSANE RAGE AGAINST ALL
THINGS TRUMP IS SO EXTREME SHE
REFUSES TO EVEN WALK ON THE SAME
SIDE OF THE STREET, NOT MAKING
THIS UP, AS A TRUMP HOTEL.
WE'VE GOT THE VIDEOTAPE.
LET'S GO TO IT.
>> I CAME IN FROM THE AIRPORT
YESTERDAY AND I GOT OFF OF THE
BUS FROM DULLES DOWN AT THE
PLAZA.
AND AS I WAS WALKING PAST WHAT
USED TO BE THE OLD POST OFFICE
BUILDING IS NOW THE TRUMP HOTEL,
IT'S JUST -- ACROSS THE STREET,
OF COURSE, BUT --
>> ARE YOU STAYING THERE?
>> GOD NO, NEVER, NEVER.
SOIP ANOTHER GREAT WITNESS.
IMAGINE, CARRYING AROUND THAT
MUCH HATRED, THAT MUCH
RESENTMENT AND ANGER EVERY DAY
OF YOUR LIFE.
PRETTY SAD, PRETTY PATHETIC.
NOT GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY.
FRANKLY, HOUSE DEMOCRATS LOOK
REALLY, REALLY STUPID.
I DIDN'T THINK HE COULD OUT DO
THE SCHIFF SHOW.
THEY DID.
FOR HAULING THAT PSYCHOTIC
INDIVIDUAL BEFORE CONGRESS.
CASE IN POINT, AFTER TODAY'S
HEARINGS, SHE MADE A DISGUSTING,
REPULSIVE JOKE ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT AND MELANIA TRUMP'S
13-YEAR-OLD SON.
WATCH THIS.
>> WHAT COMPARISONS CAN WE MAKE
BETWEEN KINGS, THAT THE FRAMERS
WERE AFRAID OF, AND THE
PRESIDENT'S CONDUCT TODAY?
>> SO KINGS COULD DO NO WRONG
BECAUSE THE KINGS WORD WAS LAW.
AND CONTRARY TO WHAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAS SAID, ARTICLE II DOES
NOT GIVE HIM THE POWER TO DO
ANYTHING HE WANTS.
I'LL GIVE YOU ONE EXAMPLE THAT
SHOWS YOU THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
HIM AND A KING, WHICH IS THE
CONSTITUTION SAYS THERE CAN BE
NO TITLES OF NOBILITY.
SO, WHILE THE PRESIDENT CAN NAME
HIS SON, BARON, HE CANNOT MAKE
HIM A BARON.
>> SEAN: SHORTLY AFTER THE
REMARK, MELANIA TRUMP RESPONDED
WITH THIS STATEMENT, QUOTE, A
MINOR CHILD DESERVES PRIVACY AND
SHOULD BE KEPT OUT OF POLITICS.
PAMELA CAROLAN, YOU SHOULD BE
ASHAMED OF YOUR ANGRY AND
BIASSED PUBLIC PANDERING AND
USING A CHILD TO DO IT.
DURING THE HEARING, CONGRESSMAN
MATT GATES ON HIS GAME, ALSO
REBUKED THE DEMOCRAT STAR
WITNESS RIGHT TO HER FACE.
GREAT MOMENT FOR HIM.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT HOW
LIBERALS WANT TO BE AROUND EACH
OTHER AND CLUSTER AND
CONSERVATIVES DON'T WANT TO BE
AROUND EACH OTHER AND THEY HAVE
TO SPREAD OUT, IT MAKES
PEOPLE -- YOU MAY NOT SEE THIS
FROM THE IVORY TOWERS OF YOUR
LAW SCHOOL, BUT IT MAKES ACTUAL
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY --
>> THE PRESIDENT --
>> YOU DON'T GET TO INTERRUPT ME
ON THIS TIME.
NOW, LET ME ALSO SUGGEST THAT
WHEN YOU INVOKE THE PRESIDENT'S
SON'S NAME HERE, WHEN YOU TRY TO
MAKE A LITTLE NOTE OUT OF
REFERENCING BARON TRUMP, THAT
DOES NOT LEND CREDIBILITY TO
YOUR ARGUMENT, IT MAKES YOU LOOK
MEAN, IT MAKES YOU LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE ATTACKING SOMEONE'S
FAMILY, THE MINOR CHILD IS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> KEY WORD, MINOR CHILD.
THE PROFESSOR ISSUED A
HALFHEARTED APOLOGY, MAKE NO
MISTAKE, IT WAS AN UNMITIGATED
DISASTER.
THIS IS WORSE THAN THE SCHIFF
SHOW.
HOW STUPID DO THEY THINK WE ARE.
THEY BRING IN THREE LIBERAL
PROFESSORS WHO LIVE AND WORK IN
THEIR IVORY TOWERS TRYING TO
CONVINCE US THAT THE PRESIDENT'S
WRONGDOING WITH NO EVIDENCE.
NOT ONLY DO THEY HAVE A CLEAR
ESTABLISHED POLITICAL BIAS AND
HATRED, BUT THEY WITNESSED
NOTHING.
THE ONLY FACT WITNESS IN THIS
ENTIRE CHARADE ONLY ONE,
TESTIFIED WHEN HE ASKED
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHAT HE WANTED
FROM UKRAINE, NOTHING.
NO QUID PRO QUO, JUST BE
HONORABLE.
THAT'S IT.
THOSE PROFESSORS' OPINIONS, THEY
DON'T MATTER.
CONJECTURE, THAT DOESN'T MATTER.
OPINION WITNESSES, THEY DON'T
MATTER.
UP IN OF THE TESTIMONY MATTERS.
THE FACTS HAVE NOT CHANGED.
JIM JORDAN OFTEN POINTS OUT, THE
FACTS ARE NOT ON THE
DEMOCRATIC -- THE DEMOCRAT SIDE
OR THE MOB IN THE MEDIA SIDE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> LET ME JUST CUT TO THE
CHASE -- THE REASON IT'S BEEN
UNFAIR IS THE FACTS ARE NOT ON
THEIR SIDE.
THE FACTS ON THE PRESIDENT'S
SIDE.
FOUR KEY FACTS WILL NOT CHANGE,
HAVE NOT CHANGED, WILL NEVER
CHANGE.
WE HAVE THE TRANSCRIPT.
THERE WAS NO QUID PRO QUO IN THE
TRANSCRIPT.
THE TWO GUYS ON THE CALL,
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND PRESIDENT
ZELINSKY SAID NO PRESSURE, NO
PUSHING, NO QUID PRO QUO.
THE UKRAINIAN THIRD DIDN'T KNOW
THE AID WAS HELD UP AT THE TIME
OF THE PHONE CALL.
AND MOST IMPORTANT, UKRAINE
NEVER STARTED, NEVER PROMISED TO
START, NEVER ANNOUNCED AN
INVESTIGATION AT THE TIME THE
AID WAS PAUSED.
NEVER ONCE.
>> SEAN: THOSE FOUR FACTS AS
CONGRESSMAN JORDAN ALWAYS SAYS,
THEY NEVER CHANGE.
IRREFUTABLE FACTS ON THE TRUMP
UKRAINE PHONE CALL IN QUESTION,
AID WAS NEVER EVER ONCE
DISCUSSED.
NOW ADD TO THAT.
FIVE SUBSEQUENT HIGH-LEVEL
MEETINGS INCLUDING ONE WITH THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AND THE PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE, ALL FIVE WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE.
THIS IS AFTER THE PHONE CALL.
AID WAS NEVER TIED TO ANYTHING
AT ANY ONE OF THE FIVE MEETING,
NEVER BROUGHT UP IN ANY WAY.
BY THE WAY, SO WHAT DID UKRAINE
DO?
WELL, BEFORE TRUMP RELEASED THE
MONEY, NOTHING.
AND THEY STILL GOT THE MONEY.
THAT WOULD BE NO QUID, PRO, OR
QUO LIKE JOE.
AND DON'T FORGET THE TRANSCRIPTS
OF THE PRESIDENT'S PHONE CALL
WITH HIM SHOWS -- REMEMBER, IT
TALKS ABOUT I WANT YOU TO DO US
A FAVOR, US, PLURAL.
HE MENTIONED IT.
HE WAS SAYING DO US A FAVOR,
TALKING ABOUT BOTH COUNTRIES.
THE 2016 ELECTION INTERFERENCE
BY UKRAINE NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE BIDENS.
BY THE WAY, EVERYONE KEEPS
SAYING CONSERVATIVES BELIEVE
THAT IF UKRAINE WAS RESPONSIBLE
FOR ELECTION AND INTERFERENCE IN
2016 AND NOT RUSSIA, IT'S A
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
NO, I NEVER SAID THAT.
WE POINTED OUT MANY TIMES ON
THIS PROGRAM, RUSSIA IS A
HOSTILE REGIME LED BY A HOSTILE
ACTOR, VLADIMIR PUTIN, WHO WE'RE
NOT GOING TO HAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY WITH, EVER.
I HAVE ZERO DOUBT THEY MEDDLED
IN THE 2016 ELECTIONS, I'M
CERTAIN THEY DID.
DEVIN NUNEZ WAS WARNING OBAMA IN
2014 IT WOULD HAPPEN.
THEY DID NOTHING.
BY THE WAY, THE DIRTY RUSSIAN
DOSSIER THAT HILLARY BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR.
ACCORDING TO "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" LATE IN THE GAME, LIKELY
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION FROM THE
BEGINNING.
AND, YES, RUSSIA INTERFERED ON
THE 2016 ELECTIONS.
THEY HAVE DONE IT BEFORE.
THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO DO IT
AGAIN.
EVERY INDICATION IS ALSO,
THOUGH, SEPARATE AND APART.
UKRAINE INTERFERED IN OUR
ELECTIONS AS WELL.
AND I HAVE NO DOUBT, OTHERS.
THE JANUARY 11, 2017 POLITICO
REPORTS IN DETAIL, THE UKRAINIAN
COURT ALSO RULED THEIR COUNTRY
INTERFERED IN OUR 2016 ELECTIONS
TO HELP HILLARY.
IT'S NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE.
HOW MANY COUNTRIES HACKED IN A
HILLARY SERVER?
THEY PROBABLY INTERFERED ALSO.
AND LOOK AT THIS, ON THE SAME
PHONE CALL, THE PRESIDENT
EXPRESSED CONCERN.
THE BRAND NEW PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE WAS SURROUNDING HIMSELF
WITH SOME OF THE SAME CORRUPT
OFFICIALS AS THE LAST PRESIDENT.
THAT'S NOT SMART.
YOU BETTER NOT DO THAT.
PRESIDENT IS REITERATED MANY
TIMES, HE DID YOU WANT WANT TO
GIVE AWAY HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS WITHOUT
KNOWING WHO IT IS GOING TO AND
HOW IT IS GOING TO BE USED.
THAT WOULD BE CALLED DUE
DILIGENCE.
IT IS THE PRESIDENT'S SWORN
DUTY.
AND BY THE WAY, ALSO, FAITHFULLY
EXECUTING THE LAWS FINDING OUT,
OH, DID THEY INTERFERE?
THAT'S GOOD FOR AMERICA TO KNOW
SO WE CAN PREVENT IT IN THE
FUTURE.
BOTH DEMOCRATS CARED FOR FOREIGN
ELECTION INTERFERENCE, THEY
DON'T.
IF THEY'RE ON A FACT-FINDING
MISSION, THEY WOULDN'T HAVE
INVITED THREE KNOWN ANTI-TRUMP
LEFT WING IVORY TOWER LUNATICS
TO GIVE THEIR BIASSED OPINIONS.
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE'S
RANKING MEMBER DOUG COLLINS
SUMMED IT UP PERFECTLY.
HE WAS ON HIS GAME TODAY.
HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN ANNOUNCED AS
THE NEXT SENATOR FROM GEORGIA.
HE WASN'T.
THANKS, GOVERNOR KEMP.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID IT A
SECOND AGO.
HE SAID WE'RE SCARED OF THE
ELECTIONS NEXT YEAR.
WE'RE SCARED THE ELECTION, WE'LL
LOSE AGAIN.
WITHE HAVE TO DO IT NOW.
THE CLOCK AND THE CALENDAR, NOT
THE FACTS.
TO SOME WAY INSINUATE THAT THE
FOUNDING FATHERS WOULD HAVE
FOUND PRESIDENT TRUMP GUILTY IS
JUST SIMPLY MALPRACTICE IN
THIS -- WITH THESE FACTS BEFORE
US.
IT'S SIMPLY PANDERING TO A
CAMERA.
IT'S SIMPLY NOT RIGHT.
IT'S NOT AN IMPEACHMENT, IT'S A
SIMPLE RAILROAD JOB.
AND TODAY IS A WASTE OF TIME.
AND THIS IS WHERE WE'RE AT.
I CLOSE TODAY WITH THIS.
IT DIDN'T START WITH MUELLER OR
THE PHONE CALL, YOU KNOW WHERE
IT STARTED?
IT STARTED WITH TEARS IN
BROOKLYN ON NOVEMBER OF 2016.
>> SEAN: GREAT POINT.
BECAUSE OF THE REAL FACTS AND
THE COMPLETE LACK.
THERE'S NO DIRECT EVIDENCE, NO
TESTIMONY.
CONSTITUTIONAL SCHOLAR JONATHAN
TURLEY WHO IS NO SUPPORTER OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE CLEAR HE
DIDN'T VOTE FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP,
HE MADE THE CLEAR AND COMPELLING
ARGUMENT AGAINST THE DEMOCRATS'
SHAM IMPEACHMENT COUP ATTEMPT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I'M NOT A SUPPORTER OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP, I VOTED AGAINST
HIM.
MY PERSONAL VIEWS OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP ARE AS IRRELEVANT TO MY
IMPEACHMENT TESTIMONY AS THEY
SHOULD BE TO YOUR IMPEACHMENT
VOTE.
THIS WOULD BE THE FIRST
IMPEACHMENT IN HISTORY WHERE
THERE WOULD BE CONSIDERABLE
DEBATE AND IN MY VIEW, NOT
COMPELLING EVIDENCE OF THE
COMMISSION OF A CRIME.
SECOND IS THE ABBREVIATED PERIOD
OF THIS INVESTIGATION WHICH IS
PROBLEMATIC AND PUZZLING.
THIS IS A FACIALLY INCOMPLETE
AND INADEQUATE RECORD IN ORDER
TO IMPEACH A PRESIDENT.
>> SEAN: JONATHAN TURLEY IS VERY
CALM, LOGICAL WAY.
HE TOOK A SLEDGE HAMMER TO THE
LEFT'S PHONY NARRATIVE.
ONE OF THE MOST POWERFUL MOMENTS
IN THE HEARING, TURLEY FLIPPED
THE SCRIPT ON THE HOUSE
DEMOCRATS.
I'M SURE THEY DIDN'T LIKE THIS
MOMENT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS GONE TO
CONGRESS -- TO THE COURTS.
HE'S ALLOWED TO DO THAT.
WE HAVE THREE BRANCHES, NOT TWO.
I CAN'T EMPHASIZE THIS ENOUGH
AND I'LL SAY IT ONE MORE TIME,
IF YOU IMPEACH A PRESIDENT, IF
YOU MAKE A HIGH CRIME AND
MISDEMEANOR OUT OF GOING TO THE
COURTS, IT IS AN ABUSE OF POWER.
IT'S YOUR ABUSE OF POWER.
YOU'RE DOING PRECISELY WHAT
YOU'RE CRITICIZING THE PRESIDENT
FOR DOING.
WE HAVE A THIRD BRANCH THAT
DEALS WITH CONFLICTS OF THE
OTHER TWO BRANCHES.
AND WHAT COMES OUT OF THERE, AND
WHAT YOU DO WITH IT IS THE VERY
DEFINITION OF LEGITIMACY.
>> THE FIRST PHASE OF THE
DEMOCRATS' IMPEACHMENT COUP
ATTEMPT, THE SCHIFF SHOW, A